but I love cooking shows and shows about
travel and stuff like that I was
actually on the Seth Meyers show Once
years ago and the other guest was
Anthony Bourdain I got to meet him real
briefly and I'm glad it was a brief
meeting because I don't want to be
backstage trading Road stories with
Anthony Bourdain
his would be like yeah I remember once I
was in South America got bitten by a
snake while I was trying to eat its
small intestine
well you know I was once at a Hampton
Inn in Little Rock
all right
and they ran out of Captain Crunch at
the breakfast buffet
porg I must have had annoying fans when
you're traveling food expert people
running up to you on the street hey
Anthony here's the deal I'm going to
Malaysia and I love turkey burgers
Anthony I'm going to Dusseldorf and I
love empanadas
I need your top five